.
GREG GUTFELD, NEXT.
>> DO YOU MISS ME?
THEY MISS ME.
[APPLAUSE]
>> I KNOW.
THEY LOOK AT THEIR BAD RATINGS
AND THEY ARE SAYING WE MISS THIS
GUY.
I SAID IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
I WAS WAITING FOR THEM TO
ENDORSE ME ACTUALLY.
I KNOW THAT WAS A BIG STEP.
>> Greg: CNN REMAINING THREE
VIEWERS SAYING, YEAH, HE'S GOT A
POINT.
[APPLAUSE]
YOU KNOW, IT'S ANOTHER GLORIOUS
MONDAY IN THIS HORRIBLY RACIST
COUNTRY.
REALLY WHAT A RACIST COUNTRY.
THAT'S HOW RACIST IT IS.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE'S PAYING ANY
ATTENTION.
NOT AFTER WHAT HAPPENED THIS
WEEKEND.
[LAUGHTER]
NOT HOW YOU OPEN A LOCKER.
I BET YOU'RE WONDERING, HOW
RACIST IS THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S SO RACIST, EVEN ITS
BUILDINGS ARE BIGOTED.
DID YOU KNOW THAT THE ROTUNDA
WHICH HOUSES THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE, U.S. CONSTITUTION
AND BILL OF RIGHTS IS GUILTY OF
STRUCTURAL RACISM.
NATIONAL ARCHIVES TASK FORCE ON
RACISM CLAIMS THE STRUCTURE
PORTRAYS OUR FOUNDING FATHERS
AND OTHER EVIL WHITE PEOPLE AS
TOO POSITIVE.
SHOCKING.
THAT THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES TASK
FORCE ON RACISM FOUND EVIDENCE
OF RACISM.
I THOUGHT THEY SAY, HEY, LOOKS
GOOD.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEND REST OF THE DAY EATING
FUNIONS IN BED.
I THOUGHT ROTUNDA WAS SPANISH
FOR FAT LADY.
ACCORDING TO THE NEW YORK POST,
THE REPORT CLAIMS THE STRUCTURAL
RACISM DEEPLY IMPACTS HOW
EMPLOYEES AND CUSTOMERS AS WELL
AS WITH THE HISTORICAL RECORD.
THEY ARE FINDING STRUCTURAL
RACISM IN THE ACTUAL STRUCTURES.
THE ROTUNDA LODGE WEALTHY WHITE
MEN -- I WONDER HOW CAN THEY SAY
THIS WITHOUT KNOWING WHICH
FOUNDING FATHER IDENTIFY AS
GENDER NON-CONFORMING.
THESE GUYS WERE WEARING WIGS WAY
BEFORE RUPAUL RACE.
HOW DID THE WHITE HOUSE SKATE BY
ON THIS?
HOW LONG BEFORE WE CHANGE THAT
NAME?
YOU SEE, THE ROTUNDA HOLDS ALL
THE MAJOR DOCUMENTS ALL WRITTEN
BY DEAD WHITE MEN.
ALL YOU SEE IS SKIN COLOR AND
GENDER, IT WILL PISS YOU OFF.
THAT SUCKS.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT.
GOING TO THE ROTUNDA AND
EXPECTING PEOPLE OF COLOR TO BE
CREDITED FOR BILL OF RIGHTS --
IT'S LIKE ME GOING TO THE WNBA
IN SEARCH OF A WIFE.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY ARE TWICE MY HEIGHT.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK OUT.
OR IT'S LIKE YOU GOING TO CNN
LOOKING FOR AN HONEST
JOURNALIST.
THE TASK FORCE SUGGEST TIPS,
HOWEVER, TO REIMAGINE THE
ROTUNDA INCLUDING STAGING DANCE
OR PERFORMANCE ART IN THE SPACE
THAT INVITES DIALOGUE ABOUT THE
WAYS THAT THE UNITED STATES HAS
THE FOUNDING ERA.
LET'S ADDRESS THE IDEA THAT
ADDING PERFORMING ARTS MAKES IT
BETTER.
THAT SUGGESTION IS PRETTY
INSULTING TO PEOPLE OF COLOR.
TO ASSUME THEY CAN ONLY
CONTRIBUTE THE CRAPPIEST OF ART,
WHICH IS PERFORMANCE ARTS, WHEN
WHITE LIBERALS HAVE NO SOLUTION,
THEY ALWAYS TURN TO PERFORMANCE
ARTS.
WHICH IS REALLY JUST
IMPROVIZATIONAL BACK SPASMS.
I'M A PERFORMING ARTIST.
NOW ABOUT THIS MYTHOLOGIZING,
THEY SAY THAT FOUNDING IS NOT
JUST EXCLUSIONARY IT'S A MYTH.
A FANTASY, SOMETHING THAT NEVER
EXISTED, LIKE BIG FOOT OR --
LIKE YOU'RE AWAKENING FROM A
DREAM AND IT'S REALLY A
NIGHTMARE WHICH HAPPENS EVERY
TIME I MIX NYQUIL WITH SKUNK
WEED.
NOW YOU COULD REWRITE HISTORY
AND COME UP WITH NEW DECLARATION
OF INDEPENDENCE.
I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY WHITE
MALE HAS TO SAY.
♪♪
THE FOUNDING FATHERS, I LOVE
THEM.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THEY DID
TO MAKE THIS GREAT COUNTRY OF
OURS.
THESE GUYS, NOT THESE GUYS.
>> THESE GUYS ARE PRETTY COOL
TOO AREN'T THEY?
COME ON.
IT MAKES ME LAUGH.
♪♪
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK THOSE
DOGS WERE THERE BY CHOICE.
I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY BLACK
MALE HAS TO SAY ABOUT THIS?
♪♪
[INDISCERNIBLE]
>> BUILDING RACIST?
WHEN YOU RING THE DOORBELL AND
IT GIVES YOU A RACIAL EPITHET?
OR, EVERY TIME A BLACKMAIL MAN
COMES TO THE MAILBOX, LEAN BACK.
YOU KNOW, IT'S KIND OF COOL THAT
WE LIVE IN A COUNTRY THAT YOU
CAN MAKE STUFF LIKE THIS UP AND
SAY WHATEVER YOU WANT AND GIVE
PLATFORM TO CALL ANYBODY IN
THEIR MOMMA RACIST EVEN IN THE
BUILDING.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH SAYS THAT YOU
LIVE IN A FREE COUNTRY THAT YOU
CAN SAY ANYTHING, NO MATTER HOW
STUPID.
SYSTEMATIC OPPORTUNITY.
[LAUGHTER]
♪♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SPEAKING OF -- AT LEAST
WE HAVE A NEW AMERICAN HERO.
GWEN BARRY, SHE TURNED AWAY FROM
THE AMERICAN FLAG AS SHE STOOD
ON THE PODIUM ON SATURDAY.
SHE SAID SHE WAS PISSED THE SONG
WAS PLAYED AS SHE RECEIVED THE
BRONZE.
CLAIMING THE TIMING WAS
INTENTIONAL.
TOO BAD THERE ISN'T A MEDAL FOR
PARANOIA.
IMAGINE BEING CAUGHT OFF GUARD.
THAT'S LIKE BEING STUN THE WHEN
YOU HEAR THE SAFETY DANCE AT A
MEN WITHOUT HATS CONCERT.
THERE YOU GO.
YOU GOT A PERSON WHO LIKE
NATIONAL ARCHIVE TASK FORCE ON
RACISM.
TAKES THINGS THAT ARE POSITIVE
AND RECAST THEM TO SOMETHING
THAT'S DEFENSIVE.
TO GWEN THE SONG IS AN ATTACK ON
HER.
I SAY THIS IS NUTS.
THAT WILL BE AN ATTACK ON
CISGENDER MEN.
WE'RE WEEK FROM JULY 4th.
OUR NATION'S BIRTHDAY.
WHY DO WE EVEN BOTHER
CELEBRATING IT?
BESIDES MIXING ALCOHOLIC DRINKS
WITH EXPLOSIVES.
IF A BUILDING CAN BE RACIST AND
SONG CAN BE RACIST AND DATE BE
RACIST TOO?
IMAGINE SOME OLD GUY DECIDE TO
SING THE NATIONAL ANTHEM.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
SHE'S UNCOVERED MORE PLOTS.
DIRECTOR AND PRODUCER, AMANDA
AMILLIA.
HIS FIRST JOB WAS AT BURGER
KING, HE CALLED OUT DEMOCRAT
WHOPPER.
T.W. SHANNON.
SHE WOULDN'T HURT A FLY.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
WOULD IT BE FUN TO SEE A RACIST
BUILDING?
>> THAT WOULD BE REAL FUN
DEPENDING ON WHO THE RACIST
BUILDING WAS MAD AT.
EVERY TIME YOU DUCK, YOU KEEP
OPENING THE COUNTER.
LIKE WHAT?
IT WILL BE LIKE NONSTOP JUST
TURN THE TV ON AND IT'S ALWAYS
ON A CROSS BURNING.
THEY'RE NOT, THEY ARE AN OBJECT.
NOT REALLY REAL.
IT SOWNES GOOD.
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF YOU
CAN SAY ANYTHING ESPECIALLY NOW.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A BETTER NAME
THIS COUNTRY TO BE UNINFORM AND
CATCH A HEADLINE ON FACEBOOK AND
GET IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA AND
JUST GO TO TOWN.
EVEN IF YOU'RE WRONG, NO ONE
WILL TELL YOU BECAUSE IT COMES
FROM YOUR TRUTH.
GOOD LUCK FINDING THE ROOTS ON
THAT ONE.
WHAT BOTHERED ME SO MUCH --
HERE'S THE DEAL.
YOU CAN HAVE TWO THOUGHTS IN
YOUR HEAD.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH ATHLETES AND CITIZENSHIP.
I THINK YOU CAN TAKE CAUSES.
THERE WAS CONSEQUENCES BUT
HISTORY LOOKS BACK, THEY ARE THE
HERO.
NOW WE CAN SAY ANYTHING WITHOUT
A FACE.
I'M AGAINST SYSTEMIC RACISM.
OKAY, WHAT IS THAT?
IT'S SYSTEMIC RACISM, IF YOU
CAN'T SEE IT, YOU'RE RACIST.
YOU CAN'T ARGUE WITH THAT.
THIS WAS MY ISSUE WITH HER, BY
TURNING HER BACK ON THE FLAG.
WHEN YOU TURN YOUR BACK, THAT
MEANS THERE'S NO HOPE.
IT'S OVER.
YOU CAN'T FIX THAT.
THAT WAS WHAT MY ISSUE WAS.
I DIDN'T HAVE ISSUES GUYS TAKING
THE KNEES DURING THE FLAG
BECAUSE THEY'RE STATING WHAT
THEY BELIEVE IN.
WHAT SHE WAS DOING WAS SIMPLY
SAYING THERE'S NOTHING TO BE
DONE.
IT'S A HORRIBLE PLACE.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE -- WHAT'S YOUR
CAUSE?
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THERE'S NO FACE TO IT.
MARTIN LUTHER KING WON.
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA WON.
WIE -- WE'RE SEEING WHAT THIS
COUNTRY IS ABOUT.
TO BE IN A SUFFICIENT PLACE TO
PULL STUNTS LIKE THIS.
SHE DIDN'T LOSE HER SPOT.
YOU CAN SAY WHATEVER YOU WANT IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT NOW.
WORDS MATTER BUT THEY DON'T
REALLY MATTER.
NO ONE IS COMING FOR HER.
CONGRATULATIONS ON TAKING AWAY
FROM THE TWO IN FRONT OF YOU.
>> Greg: THAT'S THE THING.
I FELT BAD.
I JUST FOUND OUT.
I DIDN'T WATCH ANY OF THIS.
I GOT THE NEWS OFF FACEBOOK.
I WAS DRUNK ALL WEEKEND.
LET'S BE HONEST.
T.W., THERE WERE TWO OTHER
WINNERS IN THE GOLD -- THE ONE
SHE BROKE A WORLD RECORD.
>> SHE CAME IN THIRD PLACE.
IF YOU WILL MAKE PA PROTEST, AT
LEAST HAVE THE GALL TO WIN.
I THINK EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD
STAND FOR THE UNITED STATES
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
IT IS A RALLYING CALL FOR WHO WE
ARE AS A PEOPLE.
THIS COUNTRY HAS DONE MORE TO
MAKE DREAMS COME TRUE THAN ANY
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
I DON'T KNOW WHO SHE TURNED HER
BACK ON WHETHER IT WAS AMERICA
AND NATIONAL ANTHEM.
WHAT COUNTRY SHE GOING TO LOOK
TOWARD THAT SHE WILL BE TREATED
BETTER THAN HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT I HAVE.
SHE'S PROBABLY ANGLING FOR HER
NEXT DEAL.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DO.
THEY LOOK FOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE TO SPREAD THIS
PROPAGANDA ABOUT HOW RACIST
AMERICA IS.
WHEN IT'S BEEN MENTIONED,
AMERICA IS A PLACE OF SYSTEMIC
OPPORTUNITY.
SHE WILL GO ON TO JOIN THE RANKS
LIKE MICHELLE OBAMA AND OPRAH
WINFREY AND MEGHAN MARKLE WHO
CAME TO BE OPPRESSED IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT'S PROBABLY THE FUTURE.
UNFORTUNATELY, SHE DID IT IN AT
A PLACE SHE BROUGHT SHAME ON THE
COUNTRY.
WE SHOULD ALL STAND FOR THE
UNITED STATES NATIONAL ANTHEM.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS NEAT TO
THINK THAT THE SONG WAS ABOUT
YOU.
SOMETIMES THAT HAPPENS TO ME
WHEN I'LL BE IN THE GYM I'LL
START HAVING THOUGHTS.
>> IT'S TOTALLY INSANE.
I DON'T WATCH LOT OF OLYMPICS.
I KNOW NOTHING LIKE GREAT
ATHLETES AND ALL THAT.
ONE THING I DO KNOW ABOUT THE
OLYMPICS IS THAT WHEN THERE'S
THE PEOPLE STANDING ON THE
BLOCKS, AT ANY MOMENT, THEY WILL
PLAY THE NATIONAL ANTHEM.
THAT'S THE POINT.
HOW DID SHE NOT KNOW THAT?
HOW WAS SHE SURPRISED?
I GUESS IT WAS ALL ABOUT THE
TIMING WHATEVER SHE SAID.
THE IDEA SHE SHES THEY DID IT ON
PURPOSE IS A LEVEL OF PARANOIA.
>> Greg: HAS A OLYMPIC ATHLETE
MYSELF, I WAS DEEPLY OFFENDED BY
ALL OF THIS.
>> I GOT AT PATCH AND A HAMMER
THROWING.
>> YOU HAD BUNCH OF
HAMMERS THROWN AT YOU.
I'M SURE.
>> I'M NOT SURE WHAT THAT MEANT.
>> Greg: YOU WANDERED IN A
HARDWARE STORE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I THINK IT'S REALLY GREAT THAT
YOU GOTTEN INTO HORSE BACK
RIDING.
I SAW THE RIDING CROP IN YOUR
OFFICE.
THAT MUST BE WHAT IT'S FOR,
RIGHT?
>> Greg: IT IS.
>> HAMMER THROWING.
IT IS A GREAT SPORT.
IT IS A TREMENDOUS ART TO DO SO.
I THINK THE REAL ISSUE WAS, SHE
WAS UPSET BECAUSE OF THE TIMING.
SHE'S BEEN TELLING EVERYONE WHAT
SHE WILL DO.
THEN ME PLAYED THE SONG.
SHE WASN'T READY.
SHE WAS WAITING FOR THE OLYMPICS
TO DO IT.
IT RUINED IT.
>> QUICKLY ABOUT THE BUILDINGS.
THEY RECOMMENDED TRIGGER
WARNING.
MULTIPLE HARVARD STUDIES SHOWS
BEST CASE SCENARIO THEY DO NO
GOOD.
THEY CAN POTENTIALLY CREATE MORE
HARM PARTICULARLY FOR TRAUMA
SURVIVORS.
I'M SURPRISED THIS TASK FORCE
DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
IT'S LIKE MULTIPLE PIECES O